"Ant-Man & the Wasp: Quantumania"
is almost in theaters, and critics
are finally getting a chance to see the
finished product…and they have thoughts…
When Scott Lang joined the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in 2015, no one knew what to expect.
After all, "Ant-Man" was subject to many creative
changes behind the scenes, with the most notable
being the departure of original director Edgar
Wright. However, "Ant-Man" and its sequel,
"Ant-Man and the Wasp," have proven to
be exciting additions to the MCU canon,
giving fans moments of humorous respite
amid the more high-stakes adventures of
the overarching franchise. But does "Ant-Man and
the Wasp: Quantumania" live up to expectations?
The third film in the "Ant-Man" franchise
marks the beginning of Phase 5 of the MCU,
so the titular crusader has a lot of weight
to carry on his tiny shoulders. The film sees
our heroes forced to try and navigate
the Quantum Realm, which brings them
into contact with strange creatures and their
biggest threat to date — Kang the Conqueror.
"The thing you call a life, will end."
With that in mind, what do the critics have
to say about Marvel's latest adventure? The
general consensus among reviewers on Rotten
Tomatoes is that "Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantamania" is enjoyable for the most part.
However, as a movie, it's very flawed. Several
reviewers pointed out that the film is too focused
on laying the building blocks for Phase 5, which
comes at the expense of telling a fully-formed
threequel story. Collider's Ross Bonaime wrote,
"Quantumania is a promising, but shaky start
for Phase 5 of the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
it's just a shame it comes at
the sake of the little guy."
Meanwhile, Slashfilm's Jeff Ewing noted that
the film gets Phase 5 off to a promising start,
but it's undercooked in the
grand scheme of things. He says,
"Altogether the film is an engaging and fun
start for the real meat of the Multiverse Saga,
it's also one that needs more
care and detail to flourish."
For some critics, like Jamie
Broadnax of Black Girl Nerds,
the threequel tries to integrate
several genres into its narrative,
only to experience an identity
crisis as a result. In her opinion,
"Tonally this film is different
from the other films. A bit uneven,
it feels like Jeff Loveness' script wasn't
sure what genre this movie wanted to be."
That said, IGN Movies' Joshua Yehl believes that
Marvel's latest blockbuster has
more pros than cons, writing,
"Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania
has just enough heart, humor,
and excellent performances to make up
for its more underdeveloped aspects."
Kang the Conqueror will be the Big Bad of the
MCU for the foreseeable future, with his story
set to ramp up and conclude in "Avengers: The Kang
Dynasty" and "Avengers: Secret Wars." Needless to
say, a lot is riding on the franchise's newest
formidable foe, and he has big shoes to fill
considering that Thanos once wiped out half of
the universe with a snap of his fingers. The good
news, though, is that based on what critics are
saying the new baddie is off to a flying start.
"I am Kang!"
Writing for The Guardian, Ellen E Jones praised
Majors' performance and compared the villain to
one of the most morally flawed characters
in the "Star Wars" franchise. She said,
"Majors brings the same emotionally intense it-boy
energy of Adam Driver in The Force Awakens. Note
how his eyes are often watery with empathy
for his victims, even as he throttles them."
Elsewhere, The Hollywood Reporter's Frank
Scheck praised Kang as a highlight of the movie,
noting that he brings a real sense of
"gravitas" to the proceedings. He writes,
"While it's not surprising that the actor's
imposing physicality perfectly suits his
iconic villainous character, he also invests
his performance with such an arrestingly quiet
stillness and ambivalence that you're
on edge every moment he's onscreen."
USA Today's Brian Truitt echoed these sentiments,
stating that Kang's presence covers
up some of the film's flaws, saying,
"Majors thankfully rights
the ship every time he pops
up with his deliciously disconcerting presence."